you know if I ever try and get my
daughter into doctor who I might pitch
her on this episode because she loves
wolves so much and he and the wolf dies
so maybe that wouldn't work spoilers
[Applause]
[Music]
overdue Doctor Who review we are up to
tooth and claw that's right
it is Queen Victoria and a werewolf
because why not
this one's it's kind of an interesting
one to revisit because it's by no means
a bad episode but it's always it's
number one that I've thought all that
highly of it's not like on my list of
wants to go back and revisit heavily or
anything like that but there's certainly
nothing about it that like aggravates me
like there was stuff in new earth that
just irritated me and actively annoyed
me
whereas here not so much but there are a
lot of little touches that are really
really fun about this episode I mean I
like just kind of right off the bat I
like that the doctor is you know still
not perfect at landing the TARDIS like
Oh 1876 right I love that he gets to use
his authentic accent for a little bit
that's fun
the actress who's playing Queen Victoria
quite good in the role and actually she
has a lot to do in terms of bringing
across that regal nough so like not
feeling like a caricature but at the
same time sort of living up to the myth
of what Queen Victoria it what the image
of her is I think she does a pretty
admirable job at that um there's
actually the music I want to highlight
because the the music in this episode I
actually really really like it's it's
one of the highlights of certainly of
the this series not the best that that
kind of comes later but like I do really
enjoy this track the tooth and claw
track and the music from this episode in
general it's kind of funny that as it
goes along because it's dealing with
real historical figures but in a
fantastical setting that every now and
then the doctor will point out that's
something that they're saying is in fact
true like they'll bring up the diamond
that keeps getting cut and cut down and
go oh we'll see now that's a fact like
it's like a it's a it's a fourth wall
breaking moment or talking talking about
the haemophilia is like oh no she
actually had a mutation to the blood and
like saying in such a way that actually
doesn't make total sense in the context
of the show but is obviously a wink to
the audience of wow this bits real mag
it's kind of cute I kind of like that I
really I love the moment of the doctor
seeing the werewolf for the first time
I'm just staring oh you're beautiful
with a smile on his face
and I wish we'd gotten more of that side
of Tennant's doctor during his run
because I do I do think that they leaned
heavily on the lonely god thing a bit
much for my taste and I kind of wish
there were more moments like that during
his run and I'm all but I'm always happy
to see them when they show up the
supporting cast as a whole is pretty
good the effects I'm not going to do all
on the effects because you know I have
to account for the air and the time they
do a decent enough job at sort of doing
what they can to cover for the effects
you know short and short shots he's in
the he's further back he's in shadow
he's in silhouette you know we do it's
still very of the time CGI but it does
the design solid and aside from the fact
that it doesn't integrate in the world
well but TV CGI at the time just
flat-out didn't do that it no holds up
pretty decently as far as all that goes
but there's also a lot of things here
and there that you know I'm like mmm
like it's weird to me that the that the
monks why are they pulling Shaolin monk
imagery for these guys like there's no
I'm not saying that having the them
throw off their robes and then flip
around like ninjas isn't kind of
kick-ass it kind of is but it's like why
are we mixing matching cultures here
what why are they suddenly bald Shaolin
monks with bo staffs and Ninja flips
like why especially because after the
after the cold opened that really has
nothing to do with anything like that
kind of a weird choice and I wouldn't do
well on it but it is like you're
referencing an entire different culture
with that and I don't know why like if
you're gonna do that as opposed like if
they just had you know weird their own
weird unique sort of thing because they
worship the wolf I'd actually I'm fine
with that but it's like why are they
pulling from that's but it's weird to me
and while I I don't think it's a
particularly egregious example this is
kind of at least when I first started
noticing the doctor the modern era
Doctor Who tendency to present a magical
mythological you know kind of creature
as a real thing and then just go oh yeah
well it's aliens which I've made fun of
very blatantly when I did my every
Doctor Who episode in ten words or less
video a while back that became one of
the recurring gags oh you know it's it's
a where will oh no wait it's aliens and
again while it's not aspect it's you
know overly egregious in this particular
case but I look at an isolation and it's
not even necessarily the first time it
happened that kind of goes with the
unquiet dead and the ghost but I like
this was the first time that it was the
start of it being a pattern as opposed
to just a thing that happened that one
time in that previous episode and yeah
and and that's not to say classic who
never did this but I feel like modern
who is really made a formula out of it
and one that is one I'm not a huge fan
of sort of seeing the roots of that is a
little bit hmm
the I don't love the recurring gag of of
rose trying to get Queen Victoria to say
we are not amused I think that's just
because it's sort of it's nudging up
against cringe and embarrassment humor
which is just not my bag but I don't
like that joking himself I really don't
like
became a something of a running joke I I
do want to circle back on to Queen
Victoria because I really like
especially on a rewatch that you can see
across her performance that her turn on
him at the end when she banishes him
does not come out of nowhere you pay
attention to her across the episode like
you can see the wheels turning as she's
putting these together and like getting
the sense of whatever you are about I
don't like it and I like that whole and
it it it's a nice sort of turn because
early on she's like oh yes stories of
monsters good for the blood but you know
so she does like the idea of this stuff
as stories when it starts invading her
life and her world not so much I was
like that she carries a gun and defends
herself from a [ __ ] who just calls
her woman she's the Queen and she shot
your ass but I mean overall it's just
kind of uh it's a little bit of a filler
episode out there there's a neat
callback that I kind of like with the
werewolf before he transforms sort of
recognizing in rows like you there's a
wolf thing going on with you like I that
was kind of a nice little
acknowledgement that I liked and this
sort of early planting of Torchwood
which is you know the most substantive
thing that this episode does long-term
but overall it does have a filler feel
to it which honestly most episodes where
there's a heavy focus on the monster
tend to have a filler feel on it
especially if it's you know a setting a
non extraterrestrial or extravagant
setting if it's a very basic setting but
it's like oh but there's this monster
here those episodes usually tend to feel
like filler and this one kind of does
it's it's certainly pleasant enough and
I do enjoy it and you know getting just
more of the dynamic between the Tenth
Doctor and Rose and sort of seeing you
know the seeing the the playfulness the
flirtiness of it as sort of knowing
where it goes and while I don't
that kind of relationship I can
appreciate that they are sort of
allowing that chemistry in that report
to build episode over episode so you
know Wow I again I don't love where it
will later go you know I can't say they
didn't earn it and didn't put the work
in cuz they did you can see it in these
early days they didn't just flip we're
like oh and now they're like all whoo
but like you know this feels like early
days of a relationship you know the
heavy flirting but you know we're not
officially dating yet but it's nice to
hang out you know there's a vibe you
know they capture that very well and in
terms of a progress you know from here
to where things go by the end of the
series between them no it's it's it's a
good progression but overall that there
are just a random oddities and bits of
weirdness that don't quite click about
this episode but for the most part it's
solid and that's I mean that's that's
just kind of it I don't think I put this
on my best or worst episodes written by
Davies I should've double check that
pretty sure I didn't because this is
this is very much a middle grunt oh one
though he didn't write this one yeah
dummy but of course it wasn't on there
but you know if I were to write the
overall episodes under his tenure this
would come in around the middle because
it's good it's fun yeah I enjoy it and
I'm ready for the next one again this is
not one that I've gone back and
revisited a heck of a lot aside from
just now for this so tooth and claw what
are your thoughts on it whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it whole but just up
you can do because it's buttons and
links and all sorts of stuff check out
the description there's a whole list of
things down there including a link to my
patreon but you know what you don't want
to click on that or any of it that's
soap k2 because at the end of the day
folks you're the council I just friend
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]